Good Morning America co-hosts TJ Holmes
and Amy robach's romance have ABC
staffers feeling all kinds of emotions
it is working chaos though it all
somehow figures itself out on television
but behind the scenes yes it might seem
like a madhouse The Source tells E.T
their colleagues have mixed reactions to
their relationship the ongoing drama
between Amy and TJ has some feeling like
it's not a big deal While others think
it completely taints the brand I mean
we've watched transitions before you
know on on broadcasts and network news
and in television
um and I've never been part of one like
this as for David Muir who's Amy's 2020
co-anchor he's one of those staying
neutral when it comes to the romance an
ABC spokesperson tells ET David is
focused on his work not any of this
meanwhile another source adds everyone
has been told to stay the course avoid
the distraction and keep working with
business as usual we have so much music
playing we're dancing on the set I mean
when the cameras aren't rolling we're
still dancing we're probably dancing
more we kind of have to button up when
the camera is turn on last week E.T was
told Amy and TJ are being investigated
by ABC as for why to see if the two
Valley needed any company policies
specifically the company's morality
Clause keeping the romance alive in any
relationship well maybe it's a challenge
these days just a little bit sometimes
right but when it comes to their careers
our source says Amy's always been a
highly revered journalist who's
professional and good at her job there's
no doubt she's feeling it from all sides
she loves her job and has worked hard to
cement her place as a staple at ABC it
is family and it always will be and when
it comes to TJ while Source shares he
tends to approach life a little less
seriously quote there's a hope that the
dust will settle but whether that
happens before the holidays is unclear
foreign
[Music]